What's going on, everybody?
It's your boy.
Ray Garvin here to kick off
Fantasy Week at Bleacher Report.
And fantasy football season is here
the first week of the pre-season
under way.
This is draft or pass.
We got a lot of players to talk about.
I'm excited. Football is back.
Fantasy week kicking off
and your boy Reggie Q in the building
to have some fun with you.
And what a better way to start our fantasy
we've been talking about rookies
because everybody loves rookies
and we got to see these guys play
and some of them played extended extended
time during week one of the preseason.
So let's just talk to a couple of these
rookies that people are excited about.
Should you be should you be streaming
these guys or should you be starting them
heading into week
one of our fantasy football season?
And since
I live in the great state of Texas,
we have to start with the Dallas Cowboys,
and I'm talking about Dallas Cowboys
rookie wide receiver Jalen Tolbert,
who right now is penciled in
as the starting wide receiver
for the Cowboys
with injuries to Michael Gallup.
And James Washington
was not the best debut for Jalen Tolbert.
Right. Still have a lot of hope for him
this upcoming season.
But right now he is not on the start radar
to start the season.
Somebody that you would stream you would
only play in desperate situations early.
But he's a player
that you got to keep on your radar
because as time goes on,
he definitely could develop
into a quality starter for us,
maybe a flex play.
But right now it was one preseason
game, seven targets, two receptions,
alligator armed the ball.
We're going to we're going to stream,
we're going to we're going to stream
Jalen Toliver.
We're not going to start him right now
from from the rookie from the rookies now
Kansas City Isaiah Pacheco is the hot name
and you see his ADP
not just creeping up
I mean it is on an escalator right
an elevator all the way up his ADP
continues to rise because he's playing on
one of the better offenses in the NFL
with one of the best quarterbacks
in the NFL in a running back room
that is very unproven right now.
He's running behind Clyde Edwards-Helaire
as the clear number two in Kansas City.
Isaiah Pacheco going into this season,
I didn't think much from this,
almost undrafted player,
but the way that he's been performing
in training camp
and early in the preseason, only one game.
I definitely think Isaiah Pacheco's
going to be on that start.
Radar maybe a flex guy as early as week.
One still have two more games,
but we'll see how this plays out.
Now, that player
that everybody is talking about
because he's got that dog in him, he's
got that dog in him and I'm talking about
GP George Pickens of the Pittsburgh
Steelers.
Listen he's starting he's starting wide
receiver for the Pittsburgh Steelers.
He's going to be starting from week one.
The issue with George Pickens
is the quarterback play Mitchell Trubisky.
We're here in Mason Rudolph.
Can he pick it looked
okay but I'm telling you right now,
George Pickens is somebody that I think
I think you may want to play from this
from the very start of the season week one
but we've got to get into
we've got to get into some of the other
players that we're going to talk about
with quarterbacks in particular.
We got to get into that
we want to see what I'm going to do
with some of these NFL quarterbacks,
not the rookies,
the ones that have actually played right.
So we're going to start a little
a little draft
or pass here, coming up with
with some of these quarterbacks
in the chat is active.
Please keep the comments coming in.
I see you guys talking
a little Ja'marr Chase, Deebo, Samuel
Dalvin Cook, Najee Harris.
We're going to get to all of that here
very, very shortly.
So I'll do let's
let's just take one from at home in May.
And so in man Chase or Deebo
both are going to be awesome.
Bolts are going to be fantastic.
I'm going to roll with the guy that's got
the proven NFL quarterback in Joe Burrow.
So if you're asking me right now
Ja'marr Chase to Deebo Samuel
let me give me the guy
that's catching balls from Joe from Joe
Burrow I still need to see what
what Trey Lance is going to be.
I'm excited about him this year.
Really excited about his rushing floor
and what he could what he can do.
But let's start with let's start with Joe
Burrow.
Let's go Ja'marr
Chase over Deebo Samuel 100%.
We are we are rolling with that
with that selection now
we've got quarterbacks, wide
receivers, running backs, tight ends,
defense and kicker
that we have to get to today.
So where do we want to go?
Let me see who you guys have up first
and then we'll do a little draft
or pass here
with with these guys for 20, 22
and while
we get that up I think here we go
here we go draft or pass.
Let's have some fun here.
We've got Josh Allen and Justin Herbert
and both
these players should be fantastic.
But I'm going with Josh Allen
this is this is an easy choice for me.
We're not talking Dynasty.
I'm not talking about ten years from now
this season, the most dynamic quarterback
in the NFL right now with what he can do
from the pocket with his arm
and then also the rushing ability
that he gives you.
It's it's
Josh Allen with this Buffalo offense.
The addition of James
Cook in the backfield giving him
another weapon to throw to.
We saw some Kahlil Shakir
this past pre-season.
Maybe he can develop into a competent
number three number four wide receiver
but Josh Allen playing on one of the best
on offense dynamic quarterback
going to be there red zone running back
draft draft draft Josh Allen
and that's not to discredit Justin Herbert
but we got to go with Josh Allen
to kick this thing off
no doubt about it Josh Allen
I hope you all feel the same way I know
there's some Herbert lovers out there,
but this one should be pretty simple.
Coming off the board is QB one right now.
According to underdog ADP.
We got a rock with Josh Allen on that one.
I'm seeing the chat active.
The chat is active.
Oh, all right. All right.
CeeDee Lamb or Devonte Adams.
I'm in Dallas, so anytime I see a Cowboys
player come up, I'm going to I'm
going to answer that question.
I'm going to take CeeDee Lamb.
I believe he's catching court,
catching the ball from the better
quarterback in Dak Prescott.
I like that offense.
CeeDee Lamb is the unquestioned one,
just like Davante
Adams
is the unquestioned one in Las Vegas.
I've got a little more confidence
in Dak Prescott than I do.
Derek Carr this year.
So if you're asking me CeeDee Lamb
or Devonte Adams, Cedi Lamb
playing on an offense
that does not have a Darren Waller,
that does not have a Hunter Renfroe,
even as the two
we just talked about Jalen Tolbert
at the top of the stream.
I'm going to take KD Lamb
this season over Davante Adams.
I appreciate the question
you guys got for me next
who he got for me next we did Josh Allen.
Who do we have next?
Let's do some more draft or oh,
you throw in Patty Mahomes up here.
Kansas City fans, don't be upset with me
because I love one Patrick Mahomes,
but I got a pass on Pat Mahomes
and I'm still riding with Josh Allen.
You throw Herbert up, I'm Road with Allen,
you throw Patrick Mahomes up,
I'm riding with Josh Allen.
Mahomes is awesome, but he's throwing
the three brand new receivers in.
As much as we like the rookie
Sky Moore in this Juju Smith-Schuster,
I just insisted
there are going to be some growing pains
for this offense, even though it's
probably still going to be very good.
But I am drafting Josh Allen on passing on
Patrick Mahomes Give me the stallion.
Give me the six foot five, £240 freak.
Josh Allen is the guy that we're drafting
and I love you, Patrick Mahomes.
We got a pass. We have to pass All right.
Who do you guys have for me
next? More draft or pass?
Give me give me somebody
good. Let's make this interesting.
Who do we have?
Somebody has to unseat Jojo Kay
all right.
This was the one I didn't want to see.
And people may not like it, but
I do think this is setting up very well.
For Lamar Jackson comeback season
and potentially
push for the top quarterback spot.
I'm not going to do it, though, Lamar.
I love you.
I know that you are a walking
thousand yard rusher
and Rashod Bateman
is there and Mark Andrews
but I've got to pass on you, Lamar,
and I'm still rocking with Josh Allen.
He claim the throne.
He's still at the top.
I do not believe
I'm just going to say it like this.
I don't believe there's
a better quarterback for fantasy football
in 2022 in the NFL than one Josh Allen
Lamar Jackson we love you to death
I know you're going to crush it this year.
You want to get your bag
but Josh Allen we're round with Josh Allen
we are drafting him
and passing on Lamar Jackson
that's the last quarterback
that we're going to talk about.
Nobody's unseating one Josh Allen.
So let's move on to the wide receivers.
But before we do that,
as we're getting set up,
I want to answer a couple of questions.
Young City, this is a tough one at Young
City, says Sky Moore for James Cook.
Oh, boy.
You know, running back
you Lane running back.
Right. You know, they're they're stable.
They get the work.
Unfortunately, I don't think James Cook
is going to be penciled in as a starter.
Devin Singletary
is going to get every opportunity
to carry the ball in between the twenties.
James Cook probably going to be used
as a primary pass catching running back.
Give me the guy that's probably
on the field with Patrick Mahomes.
70% of the time
I'm taking Sky Moore over James Cook.
So our quarterback room, Josh Allen
sitting at the top.
We're moving on to wide receivers
for some draft or pass.
Are we ready for the wide receivers?
We've got one more one more question.
One more question.
Carr is better than Dak from Baytown.
I disagree with you there,
but I like me some Derek Carr
but I'm still taking Dak Prescott over.
Derek Carr ten out of ten times.
I love the addition of Davante Adams,
but yeah, we're still rolling with Dak
for this year and Dak still gives you.
I know
he's not the Konami code of the past, but
he does still have some touchdown upside
on the ground rushing as well,
whereas Derek Carr probably not his forte.
So I'm still taking Dak Prescott over.
Derek Carr, love it.
They'll love it. Love the conviction.
Love the conviction.
They're big town,
but we're still Roman with Dak Prescott.
And I promise you
that is not a byproduct of being a homer.
Here in Texas.
I'm very objective
when it comes to those type of things.
At least I like to say our right.
Where are we at draft or passer?
We ready for some wide receivers.
I think we got some good young wide
receivers I'm going to talk about.
Maybe some are some sleeper
kind of guys up.
Here we go.
All right. All right, all right.
Let's put the homer ism aside.
I do like what Jalen Tolbert could
potentially bring to the Cowboys offense
as the number two catching passes
from Dak Prescott.
But we're passing on Jared Toliver.
Get him off of the screen this is simple.
This is a warm up.
It's Devonte Adams. Give me Ty Adams.
The unquestioned number one
target in Las Vegas is year
paired up with his old college buddy,
Derek Carr.
They're probably going to make sweet
music in Las Vegas this year.
Is it going to be as good as what it was
when he was playing with Aaron Rodgers?
I doubt it, because he's one of the most
if not the most efficient quarterback
to ever play the game in his prime.
But that was an easy one.
I just had to throw Tolbert out there.
I wanted to talk about him and keep
or keep him on your radar.
But that's an easy one.
The Vontae Adams
Let's get it out to Adams.
Jalen Tolbert Easy peasy.
What do we got next?
Who do we have next?
Who's going to who's going to challenge
Vontae Adams here on this
draft a past 2022 fantasy edition
empty.
Okay, let me just say this.
The answer is Davante Adams
but but but but but but.
The big thing with Michael
Thomas is we did not think
or we did not know how healthy that ankle
was going to be going into the season.
And based on every piece of information
that I've been able to gather from the New
Orleans Saints training camp, these back
looking like empty of the past.
And we know Drew Brees isn't there,
but Michael Thomas, healthy
and on the field is the number one target.
And he is going to get every opportunity
to just command
a ridiculous target, share
and I think he's in for a big season,
but I can't take that leap
and take him over Devonte Adams.
But empty
if empty versus some other players, I may
I may shock y'all and take Michael Thomas,
but the answer here is we're drafting
Devante Adams
and we are passing on Michael Thomas.
But I want empty
and you should one empty as well.
His ADP is constantly rising
as more and more positive reports
out of training camp start to emerge.
But we got to roll with Devonte Adams
with that one.
So the Matt Adams is two for two.
Nobody has really challenged him yet.
So hopefully we get a couple of players
up here that we could see will potentially
unseat one Devonte Adams who we got
no we got next on draft or pass away.
Okay.
And there we go.
There we go.
Just just Devonte, we love you.
But Justin Jefferson,
Minnesota Vikings wide receiver,
third year pro right regression last year.
There's no way he can he could replicate
what he did as a rookie.
No, he did.
And you're right,
he just was better than what
he was his rookie season
and this new Kevin O'Connell on offense
everybody they're saying Justin
Jefferson is uncover a bull at Vikings
training camp is easy
I'm get Justin Jefferson
give me a chance Jefferson Monday Tuesday
Wednesday advisers Sunday Monday
every day of the week Justin Jefferson
we are drafting him Davante Adams
you represented yourself
well but we got a pass pass on you now
Justin Jefferson we are drafting him
I don't think a 1700 yard season
is out of the realm of possibility
for Justin Jefferson this year.
He should go absolutely berserk
and I'm excited for him.
Kirk Cousins opening up Justin
Jefferson were drafting him so long Davon
tell you it was fun
but his jets turn now let's go one of the
best young wide receivers in the NFL
Well the best wide receivers
we've seen come in the NFL's
those first couple of years Justin
Jefferson absolute stud were drafted him
who we got
we got who we got who we got who we got.
Oh the last one
the last one to saved the best for last.
This is tough because we got the Triple
Crown winner himself, Cooper Kupp,
who just completed
the greatest wide receiver season
ever in the history of the NFL.
And, you know, they won the Super Bowl
and they're running it back
with Matthew Stafford.
He gets some help opposite of him
with Allen Robinson.
This is tough.
This one.
This is the hardest draft to pass
that we've done yet.
And I've got to stick with Jess.
I know Cooper Cup is going to do
the damn thing this year.
He is going to ball out.
He's got two catches, 100 balls.
He's going for 1500 yards.
He's going to score. He's
going to be awesome.
But that season that he had last year,
I do not think he can duplicate that.
That was all time greats Justin Jefferson.
We are drafting Justin
Jefferson and passing on Cooper Kupp.
Let me know what you all think.
Let's head to the chat real quick
before we run into running backs
and let me see what we got here.
Here we go. Dalvin Cook.
Ah, Najee Harris, NPR.
Very, very good question.
This is, this comes from
who has this Keegan refer.
Thanks for the thanks for the chat.
Dalvin Cook.
A lot more efficient than Najee Harris.
This year.
I think he's going to be
a much more efficient player.
But that Pittsburgh offense
is going to be bad.
Mitch Trubisky, Mason, Rudolph,
Kenny, pick it.
I don't care who it is.
Everything is going to flow through.
Najee He's going to be volume dependent
and he may volume his way
to being the top running back this season.
I think I'm going to take Najee
Harris over Dalvin Cook, but
this is close
because Minnesota's offense is better.
I think it's going to be more efficient
in Minnesota.
But Najee Harris playing 90 something
percent of the snaps last year unheard of.
And there's nobody to challenge them.
We're going to go with Najee Harris over
Dalvin Cook volume based approach
and then that's a great Segway
because we're going to ride
into the running backs and BOLO draft
or pass running back edition.
So who do you have for me at quarterback
so far?
We got Josh Allen, Justin Jefferson, and
we start off with a very difficult one.
Of course, Austin Ekeler or the King,
Derrick Henry comeback season for one.
Derrick Henry, who amazingly missed
half of the season and was still a top
ten rusher in the league.
Just, just insane
what Derrick Henry has done
throughout the course of his career
as the starting running back.
But I'm going to take
Austin Ekeler
he's just the efficiency monster.
He's getting the work
in the receiving game.
He's going to do enough on the ground.
Touchdown upside Justin Herbert
I like the offense better.
They improve the offensive line
with Rashawn Slater last year.
They take Zion Johnson,
the guard out of Boston College.
You know the wide receivers are there.
Tennessee it's all King Henry.
I mean, I love Trey Lon,
but it's all King Henry.
I love you, King. But we have to pass.
Give me Austin Ekeler, who I believe
might be the second best running back
for fantasy football purposes
this year behind Jonathan Taylor.
Love the king.
But we're rocking with Austin Ekeler,
who we got who's going to unseat Austin
Ekeler.
We're going to make it a conversation.
We got to make it a conversation.
Okay. All right.
This is an easy one, right?
It's Austin Ekeler, but I wanted to bring
Isaiah Pacheco up here
because he is getting the hype.
We've seen his ap rise
by 27, 28, 29 slots over the past week.
And as the preseason continues to go on,
I know that the enthusiasm around
Pacheco is only going to grow.
But don't be silly, folks.
This is.
I'm seeing people out here
reach to epic proportions.
Remember a couple of years ago
when people were telling us
Clyde Edwards-Helaire should be drafted
one on one in fantasy?
Don't make that mistake again.
Pay attention as they have Pacheco,
somebody that needs to be on our radar.
Some of that we're probably going to play,
but do not I repeat, do not put him
in the category is being a top
12 running back
this season the top 15 running back
I see I see people making this mistake
early on past get Pacheco off the score
get Pacheco out of there no Isaiah Pacheco
good streamer
somebody we need to pay attention to
But do not be silly folks
Do not put him in the top 1015
any of that right now
Let's let it play out Austin Ekeler Easy
peasy
Who we got next Who we got next year?
Who who's going to take down?
Oh, boy,
there he is The man, the myth, the legend
One of the greatest fantasy
seasons of all time when Christian
McCaffrey, who was burned us
two years
and I know a lot of people out there.
You just the taste is in your mouth
and you just like.
I can't I can't do it with cs and Andrew.
Listen, I'm
not factoring any injury, right?
We're looking at where they are today.
And right now
Chris McCaffrey's hamstrings are healthy.
Chris McCaffrey's plan there's an upgrade
at quarterback with Baker Mayfield.
I'm actually going to have some conviction
here, folks.
I think if there's any running back
that can challenge
JT to be the guy this season, it's
Christian McCaffrey.
We know what he can do
in the receiving game.
He's going to get his fair
share work in the running game.
They bring in a competent backup
and Deonte for men.
I'm actually going to draft
Christian McCaffrey
over Austin Ekeler with the projection
to say at the end of the season,
when we look back, CMC is still that dude,
he's still that
man and he's going to help us win
some fantasy championships this fall.
I'm not worried about the last two years.
Give me some Christian McCaffrey.
I'm in on Christian McCaffrey
here in 20, 22.
So Austin Ekeler,
you had a nice little run.
Joe off the screen.
Christian McCaffrey
We got you in the build and baby Christian
McCaffrey do we got one more,
one more that we can kind of talk about.
Do we have somebody else
from the running back position
that we could bring up here?
And there it is.
What a beautiful segway behind the scenes.
Johnathan Taylor
and he's the RB one, right?
You got to draft JT is the RB one.
Don't get cute.
I know. I talked all that stuff
about Christian McCaffrey.
I talked all that hot noise
about Austin Eklund challenging.
They may challenge, but the king is
the king and Jonathan Taylor fantasy
football here in 2022 he is the king
and you got to draft him at the top
Christian McCaffrey pass you're done
Jonathan Taylor
welcome to my squad I want you let's go JT
we're passing on Christian McCaffrey
and we are rocking with Jonathan Taylor
and listen
you could put somebody else up there
but I'm just telling you right now
we are going to pass
because it's Jonathan Taylor.
But if we want to talk
about another running back
and you want to throw it on the screen,
we can.
But JT is the one will be the one
and should probably return RB one value
this season.
How player value number one overall
he's just set to smash
Matt Ryan in that offense.
Looking good and JT is the last
so JT is last is not a chat let's see
what the people are saying now the cowboys
question you know you know the way to
my heart is to bring up Cowboys players
Saquon Barkley or Ezekiel Elliott.
Listen, if y'all
watch the preseason like I did, the Giants
are probably not going to be good.
I'm sorry, Giants fans,
but Daniel Jones just is not.
It's the only player that I want on
that offense.
Is Saquon Barkley.
And if you're asking me Saquon or Zeke,
give me Saquon Barkley.
I know he's going to be involved in the
in the passing game.
He's going to get all the work
on the ground.
Give me Saquon Barkley again,
another player who's suffered injuries
over the past couple of years.
So that taste in fantasy
gamers mouths is a little sour.
But don't don't trip. Don't trip.
Just take one. It's going to be all right
this season. All right.
We've got tight
ends, tight ends, the position
that you probably could stream
the most in fantasy.
But if you have an elite guy,
an elite player,
that point per game differential
that you get with one of the elite titans
is one of the biggest gaps in fantasy
football next to the quarterback position.
So this draft, the pass is very important
with some of these tight ends.
So let's get
some tight ends up on the board
and have a little battle royale
with some of these tight ends right here.
Who do we got off?
Everybody's
favorite tight end, Kyle Pitts.
And then the tight end of the people,
the people's champ, George Kittle.
Oh, boy. This is this is tough.
This is tough.
Kyle Pitts might just see
ridiculous, a ridiculous target
share this year outside of Drake London.
Does anybody can anybody name five
wide receivers for the Atlanta Falcons?
Because I cannot.
Kyle Pitts is the play
we are drafting Kyle Pitts
and we are unfortunately passing
on our man, a George Kittle
who should be in line for a good season
young quarterback
probably going to be a lot of rushing
for the San Francisco 49 ers this year
we know George Kittle went healthy
one of the best tight ends in football
but we got to make it
we got to make that bet
and Kyle Pitts having a thousand yards
as a rookie coming in
with no target competition outside of a
rookie wide receiver in Drake London
we are drafting Kyle Pitts
passing on George Kittle
love you George but this year
we got a rock with Kyle Pitts
the unicorn himself
hopefully you'll agree with that one.
Let's see who's going to challenge
Kyle Pitts to unseat this guy,
because I don't know
if he's going to stay there.
And here we go.
Travis Kelsey, we talked about
Patrick Mahomes a couple of minutes ago.
And in all the losses at the wide receiver
position, no.
So Tyreek Hill, you got him
this coming in, Juju Smith-Schuster
the one constant,
the best tight end in football.
He's been the best tight end in football
since, you know, over the last five,
six years.
Travis Kelce, I do not
I do not think it's crazy to
to say 1500 yards is within the range
of possibilities for Travis Kelce.
He is he is going to face that offense.
Will run through Kelsey.
I get Clyde,
I get to check all this other stuff.
Kelsey, Kelsey, Kelsey could be in
for the best season of his career
devoid of wide receiver weapons there.
Kyle Pitts, baby, I love you and Dynasty.
I'm taking you, Kyle.
You know I'm taking you in dynasty
but here in 2022
give me Travis Kelsey
catch and pass passes
from Patrick Mahomes
as the unquestioned number one target
by Kyle Pitts and hello Travis Kelsey
who do we got next
to who we got next on this draft the pass
and I know it's going to be good.
Damn it.
It is.
It's man Rose it's Mark Andrews
Baltimore Ravens
All-Pro tight end
who just went ballistic last season.
I want to do it all.
I want to say Mark Andrews,
Mark Andrews, Mark Andrews.
But the answer is still Travis
Kelce for 2022 I just
he is probably the best tight end option
this coming season
because he is the unquestioned number one
target playing with one of the best
if not the best quarterback in the NFL
and Patrick Mahomes in as much as I love
Lamar Jackson
you know that we know that
throwing the ball is not his his forte
he could do it don't get it twisted
but I want Travis Kelce
I want the player the number one target
catching passes from Patrick Mahomes
a lot of people really excited about
Russia Bateman this year I think Andrews
is probably poised for tight end
two tight end three season this year.
But we're going to pass on Mark Andrews
and we are going to draft one.
Kyle Pitts, not Kyle Pitts, Travis Kelce.
Good night. I'm thinking Dynasty.
I love you, Pitts.
I'm sorry, but Travis Kelsey's
the play added to the tight end spot.
And we are going to go to the chat
to see what else is going on.
Okay.
I see Goat Man.
He just said,
Sutton, is this year's Cooper Cup.
I wouldn't go that far,
but I am excited about Courtland Sutton.
I'm very excited.
And I do think Courtland Sutton
is going to be the one for Russell
Wilson in Denver.
Love it, love it, love it.
A rookie wide receiver to draft
rookie wide receiver to draft.
Let's go deep and let's say
I think a sneaky late draft target.
Not going to say Trey
Lundberg Straight London Romeo Dubs.
I'm in Romeo Dobbs. Excuse me, Mr. Dobbs.
I'm mad.
He's going to play playing with the most
efficient quarterback in NFL history.
And Aaron Rodgers.
Romeo Dobbs is the rookie wide receiver
to draft late, late, like late.
Do not draft him
early. Do not draft them early.
Draft him late.
And I think we're going to go to defense
and we'll just talk quickly
about these defenses because there are
some good ones in the NFL.
I know a lot of you still out there
play with team defense is that you want
those turnover first assistant draft
or past defensive additions.
And that's what I like.
I played defense in college
stocks and defensive side of the ball
and let's get into that.
So we are going to go with the Rams
versus the 40 niners
you know Bobby Wagner Aaron Donald
Jalen Ramsey
you got turnovers on every level
got players getting after the pass rush
I know they lost Von Miller
Nick Bosa on one side of the ball
Eric Armstead
Fred Warner we're going with the Rams
I think this addition of Bobby Wagner
to this defense
you guys this is having a dynamic weapon
like Bobby Wagner
that can just patrol the mental stuff
the run you still have one of the greatest
defensive players of our generation
in Aaron Donald Manning that front line
and one of the best
if not the best secondary defender
in the league and Jalen Ramsey
give us the Rams give us the Rams.
Rams, we are drafting the Rams.
We're passing on San Francisco,
even though that defensive line
and that front seven
for San Francisco is going to create
massive issues this year in the AFC West.
And the good thing is
we get to see these two teams play twice
this season, but we are drafting the Rams
and passing on the passing on the San
Francisco 40 Niners for 2022.
Who else do we have.
I know we got a couple of good team
defenses that we need to talk about
and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers right
you know this was a team that defensively
started off really hot last year.
You could not run against Tampa Bay
but you could exploit them through the air
and we saw that happen multiple times
this one for me is easy.
I still want the Los Angeles Rams.
I think this defense is poised
for an absolute monster season.
Tampa Bay, I'm interested to see how some
of these new defensive players play out
for the Bucs.
We know Tom Brady is a little absent.
He took a little vacation in training camp
knowing endowment can sue this year.
Hopefully some of the players that they
picked last year in the draft step up.
But this one is easy for me.
Give me the Rams over
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers for 2022.
Who else do we have
that could potentially unseat the Rams
and I've got a feeling I know
what team is popping up and there we go
the Buffalo Bills you know this is
this is a great Segway because L.A.
loses Von Miller Buffalo games von Miller
they draft
young potential stud cornerback
Kaya Elam to help solidify that secondary
I know they had had one of the injuries
back I believe it was Mike Hyde
that was injured was Micah Hyde
or maybe the other safety
but Buffalo Main Edmunds,
that middle linebacker are all the reports
on and Oliver at the defensive line
playing better an opportunistic defense.
Here's why I say Buffalo.
AFC East right
the Jets the Patriots, the Dolphins,
they get those teams,
you know, 66 games against
they're against they're they're
they're they're division foes.
And I think Buffalo's going to force
a ton of turnovers.
So as much as I like the Rams
I think I would rock with the Buffalo
Bills over the Rams for this season.
This is a turnover turnover
opportunistic type defense.
I love some of the additions
that they made.
And you know with the Rams you still have
to worry about getting through
the NFC West as well as the conference
that they play this year.
You guys the AFC West, right?
The Raiders, the Chargers, the Chiefs
and the Denver Broncos.
So give me Josh,
give me the Josh Allen led Buffalo Bills.
But we're going to go
the defensive side of the ball.
We are drafting the Buffalo Bills Rams.
You had a good run.
You're out of here.
We're going with the Buffalo Bills.
We're passing on that one
and they wrap it up for us.
The Buffalo Bills
end up victorious on this one.
Love what that defense
could potentially do.
Let's go back to the chat.
And since we're talking defense,
sleeping on the coach,
do not sleep on the couch, Steve.
We didn't put him
up. Can't go to everybody.
But the Colts defense is going
to be really nice this year as well.
Again, look at the division, the Titans,
the Texans, really the Jaguars.
You got to think about all of that stuff.
When your pick and defense is, folks,
you got to look at who they're playing
and the quarterbacks that those
those teams are going to be, you know,
facing this season and that that AFC
South is not a good division.
So I do think that the Colts defense
is a nice sleeper type defense.
People are saying
San Francisco are the Ravens.
Give me San Francisco easy peasy
and one more Broncos or Chargers
oh man.
Can I just say neither I just
don't want to deal with the AFC West.
There's just going to be points
galore in the AFC West
both those defenses look good.
If you're asking me right
now, Ray, goddammit, tell me right now
I'm asking the question.
Give me one.
I'm going to say the Chargers
defense over the Broncos.
But let's get to the most important
position in football.
I know you guys have been
waiting for this.
The kickers, let's get into some kicker
talk draft or pass kicker additions.
And we saw Justin Tucker crack
the top 100 Tyler Bass or Justin Tucker.
Give me the leg of Justin Tucker.
Listen, Tyler Bass doing his thing.
Top five kicker this year.
But I know the Ravens trust him.
They just paid him to be the highest paid
kicker in NFL history.
Justin Tucker is the play that I want.
And you know, with Jake Dobbins
potentially starting off a little slow
if Lamar can't convert him in the end
zone.
A lot of field goal opportunities
for the Baltimore Ravens.
Give me Justin Tucker pass on Tyler Bass.
Give me Justin Tucker and now it's
Ryan suck up or Justin Tucker.
And again, I think there are only
a handful of kickers
that I'd rather have than Justin Tucker
this season.
And unfortunately,
Ryan Succop is just not that kicker,
especially for those of you
who get points for field goal distance.
Justin Tucker,
I mean, he's going to get his
you know, 1050
plus field goal yard attempts this season.
We're going with Justin Tucker
redrafting him passing on Ryan suck up.
Come on, let's get somebody in here.
And here's the guy I wanted to talk about.
Evan McPherson exploded on the scene
last year as a rookie.
The the offense of the Bengals
better offense
then the Baltimore Ravens
potentially more scoring opportunities.
You know,
we want Joe Burrow to convert those with
maybe a couple of additional opportunities
in the red zone inside the 30
for Evan McPherson to go out there
and continue on his magical rookie season.
I think we're going to pass on old man
Tucker your beast JT you are a beast
but we're going to roll with that new kid
on the block, Evan McPherson
and the Cincinnati Bengals.
We are drafting Evan McPherson.
And do we have anybody else
that's going to challenge McPherson or is
or is that the last one?
That may that may be the last one.
Evan McPherson right there.
I know Tucker
Carlson from the Raiders is somebody else
that I'm that I'm high on from the.
Yeah. Daniel Carlson.
I said Tucker Carlson. Oh, my goodness.
Daniel Carlson.
Number one kicker this year
and I agree with you, Daniel
Carlson is a very, very good kicker,
but I love me some Evan McPherson.
If anybody's going to challenge
those guys, I do believe it is Carlson.
So let's go to chat for one last time.
I'm with you some quick hitters
Mitch Trubisky or a ham sandwich.
You add some lettuce and tomato on it,
and I think I'm going to take the ham
sandwich over Mitch Trubisky.
Would you take CMC at number two PPR?
I don't hate it.
He's the only guy that I believe
truly has the type of upside to compete
with Jonathan Taylor.
At the top. Thoughts on D.J. Moore.
Love. D.J.
Moore can't stand
the quarterback situation in Carolina.
And the final one
we're going to take a look at here
Cam Acres are Saquon Barkley,
tough one right now.
They've got Cam Acres and Darrell
Henderson listed as coach starters
for the Rams.
I excited for Acres.
I want Acres, but I know Saquon
Barkley is the top dog in New York.
I know he's going to get
every opportunity.
The offense is
not as good as the Rams at all.
So the efficiency may be an issue
for Saquon Barkley,
but you're asking me right now
Saquon or carmaker's.
I'm going with Saquon Barkley.
No, doubt.
Let's do a quick recap
of some of the draft or past players
that we pick a look at our roster
that we kind of build here.
We talk to a lot of quarterbacks,
but at the end of the day,
Josh Allen is QB one for 2022
draft him as such wide receivers
we can have a conversation.
Some of you may be watching this
and saying
that Ray Cooper Kupp is that guy
I want ja'marr chase look what he did
we went with Justin Jefferson
I think he is in line to have a Cooper
Kupp esque season for the Vikings in year
three Just getting better and better
Justin Jefferson running back
what would Jonathan Taylor
the stud out of Indianapolis
you know he's RB one
unless Christian McCaffrey or Austin
Meckler Najee Harris unseats him
JT Travis Kelsey 1500 yards
bucket is going to ball out this year and
one of the beautiful things about Kelsey
since his second season in the NFL
the most durable tight end in the NFL.
He has not missed a game
that the chiefs have not held him out
for playoff purposes.
Travis Kelce a beast defense
the rams had a good run
but we went with the Buffalo Bills
and kickers.
Yes Daniel Carson is good
Justin Tucker is good.
But in this edition of Draft a Pass,
we went ahead and went with the Cincinnati
Bengals young young stud Evan McPherson.
So, hey, I appreciate your tapping in
for this first, first draft
to pass the fantasy football season here
in 2022 over at Bleacher Report.
Thank you everybody in the chat.
I hope this was a fun, entertaining show
and most importantly actionable.
So for Ray Garvin
you can find me on Twitter at Ray GQ
Bleacher Report draft pass fantasy
2022 edition.
I think we're going to go ahead
and get up out of here I appreciate
you all have a good one I'm out base